[Music]
often times as homeowners we're required
to use pesticides to control certain
problems those problems being insects
diseases and weeds and so once you've
chosen the product that you're
interested in using the important thing
to do is read the label that comes with
the packet if you find that the label is
difficult to read or or difficult to
understand you can actually go to the
internet and type in in your web browser
that product's name and then the word
label and you can get a more readable
version of that particular product's
information some of the information
that's included in the label that you
need to be aware of is the active
ingredient the statement about first aid
and if you happen to have a problem
where you are required to go to the
medical facility and be treated you
probably need to take the label with you
and Hazards both to animals and to
yourselves that are included in that
particular product uh there might be
particular statements about um bees and
how that product would affect bees and
then specifically it'll start to get
into the directions for use and then
finally there'll be information on
storage and Disposal and so what you
want to remember when you buy a product
it's really important to read and
understand and follow that label that
comes with it in order for you to apply
that product correctly and then be able
to dispose of that container when you're
done with it this is Jeff Edwards for
the University of Wyoming extension from
the ground up
[Music]